- Valérie Rabault:
La séance est ouverte.
La présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale
m'a demandé de présider
cette séance
de questions au gouvernement.
Elle se trouve
actuellement à Prague,
où elle participe au deuxième
sommet parlementaire
de Crimée,
manifestant le soutien
que les démocraties
apportent à l'Ukraine.
Applaudissements
L'ordre du jour
appelle les questions
au gouvernement.
La parole est à madame
Fatiha Keloua-Hachi.
- Fatiha Keloua-Hachi: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à la ministre
de l'Enseignement
supérieur
et de la Recherche.
En 2017,
le candidat En Marche
à la présidence nous promettait
la construction
de 60.000 logements
étudiants
et de ne plus avoir personne
qui dorme
dans les rues.
Sans surprise,
cette promesse
est non tenue.
Depuis 2022,
c'est devenu l'habitude,
les promesses non
tenues et les 49.3,
qui s'enchaînent
de semaine en semaine.
Même si on ne s'attend
à rien,
on est quand même déçus.
"Indigne", voilà
le mot qui me vient
à l'esprit quand je pense
aux conditions
de vie et d'études de nos jeunes.
Indigne, quand 8
logements sur 100
sont vides,
mais que les étudiants dorment
dans la rue ou dans leur voiture.
Indigne, quand 12%
des étudiants renoncent
à leurs projets d'études,
faute de logement.
Crise du logement,
baisse des APL,
hausse des prix
de l'énergie, servir
les plus riches
pour déshabiller
les plus pauvres,
encore et toujours.
Les étudiants
ne veulent
plus de vos mesurettes.
Ils veulent s'émanciper
et vivre dignement,
de manière autonome.
Surtout, ils attendent
que le gouvernement tienne enfin
ses promesses,
en assurant à chacun
un logement.
Madame la ministre,
quel dispositif d'urgence
mettez-vous en place
pour ne laisser
plus aucun étudiant dormir dehors?
C'est une question de dignité.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Sylvie Retailleau.
- Sylvie Retailleau: Merci.
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la députée,
je vous remercie
pour la question.
Ca me donne
l'occasion de dire
ce que ce gouvernement
et cette majorité
fait pour les étudiants
dans le cadre
du logement.
Le logement
étudiant,
comme tous les logements
aujourd'hui, connaît
une crise.
30.000 logements étudiants
ont été réalisés
depuis 2017.
Aujourd'hui,
le logement étudiant
fait partie d'une
crise du foncier.
Nous identifions
avec le ministre
du Logement
le foncier disponible
pour pouvoir continuer
cet engagement
de passer de 30.000
logements déjà réalisés
aux 60.000 logements.
C'est travailler
dans de bonnes conditions
pour les étudiants,
vous l'avez dit.
Dans ce cadre,
12.000 logements
sur les 175.000 logements
du CROUS restent
à être rénovés.
Nous avons déjà planifié
cette rénovation
de ses 12.000 logements.
4000 sont en cours actuellement.
8000 sont planifiés jusqu'à 2027.
Nous avons augmenté les APL.
Cette majorité a aussi gelé
les droits d'inscription,
mais aussi les restaurations.
Nous avons mis
sur la table,
pour cette rentrée,
1,5 milliard
de plus pour la vie étudiante,
en particulier
sur cette étape des bourses.
Cette majorité,
depuis 10 ans,
a fait le plus sur la réforme
des bourses
et sur l'augmentation
aux étudiants.
Merci.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
Madame la députée?
- Fatiha Keloua-Hachi:
Je retiendrai...
- Valérie Rabault:
Un peu de silence.
- Fatiha Keloua-Hachi:
Je retiendrai
les 12.000 logements
et la rénovation.
J'espère
que ce ne sera pas une énième
promesse non tenue.
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à Sébastien Chenu.
- Sébastien Chenu:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre.
La semaine dernière,
des manifestations
se sont déroulées
jeudi dernier,
en particulier sous les sinistres
cris "Allahu akbar".
Cela s'est fait
à quelques mètres
du Bataclan,
quelques jours
après le décès et l'assassinat
de monsieur Dominique Bernard.
Les Français sont inquiets.
Ils sont choqués.
Avec les députés
du Rassemblement National
et Marine Le Pen,
nous sommes la voix
de ces Français
choqués, inquiets
et exigeants.
Vous avez,
pendant des années,
criminalisé
ceux qui ont lancé l'alerte.
Il en a fallu
du courage, pour nous,
pour des militants
et des intellectuels,
pour dénoncer
cette menace islamiste
dans notre pays.
Il nous a fallu
du courage pour s'opposer
à votre déni, à cette gauche
qui présente Israël
comme un régime
d'apartheid, qui présente
le Hamas comme une armée légale.
Il en a fallu,
du courage,
pendant des années.
Aujourd'hui,
comme vous le savez,
nous avons fait
un certain nombre
de propositions de loi
pour nous opposer
à l'islamisme et à son danger.
Allez-vous nous donner
les moyens juridiques
et législatifs de combattre
cette idéologie,
de lutter contre ces expressions
politiques, intellectuelles,
culturelles, vestimentaires
et son apologie
à travers les manifestations,
ou allez-vous continuer
à interdire
des manifestations
qui se déroulent quand même?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le député Chenu,
vous aurez constaté
que nous avons été
très clairs
et nous avons été
les seuls en Europe
à le faire.
Nous avons interdit
toutes les manifestations
pro-Hamas
qui se sont tenues
dans les heures
et les jours
qui ont suivi.
Contrairement
à ce qui s'est passé
à Berlin, à Londres,
à Washington,
en 2013 et en 2014,
la police
de la République a pris
ses responsabilités.
En effet,
nous avons constaté
que la justice
administrative a autorisé,
parce qu'elle a réformé
la décision
du préfet de police,
la manifestation
qui s'est déroulée
dimanche dernier.
La plupart
des manifestants
se sont comportés
de façon convenable.
Les slogans antisémites,
inacceptables, ignominieux,
n'ont pas été condamnés
par les partis politiques
qui ont organisé
cette manifestation...
Il y a eu plus d'une vingtaine
d'interpellations
des personnes.
La consigne donnée
à tous les préfets
de la République,
c'est d'interdire
les manifestations
qui se dérouleront
contre l'ordre public
et qui peuvent poser
des questions.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
- Sébastien Chenu:
Monsieur le ministre,
force est de constater
que votre loi
sur le séparatisme
n'a rien changé.
Il faut une législation
particulière.
Nous la réclamons
avec Marie Le Pen,
il faut une loi qui combat
et empêche l'expression
et la visibilité
de cette idéologie islamiste.
Vous ne nous la présentez pas
aujourd'hui.
Il ne faut pas
attendre
qu'il soit trop tard.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à Jérémie
Patrier-Leitus.
- Jérémie Patrier-Leitus: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre.
"60 ans plus tard,
je suis toujours hantée
par les images et les odeurs
des camps d'extermination
de la Shoah.
" Je resterai hanté
par le visage
de ces enfants qui furent
tués à bout portant
devant leurs parents.
Madame la Première
ministre,
si je me permets
d'évoquer l'atrocité
de ce que j'ai vu
à Israël,
c'est que je n'ai pas supporté
les voix
qui se sont levées
dans notre pays
pour parler de crimes de guerre.
Il y a eu
une rhétorique
que je n'ai pas supportée.
Madame la Première
ministre, le président
de la République
est en Israël
pour porter la voix de la France.
Notre pays connaît la pire
attaque terroriste
depuis les attentats de Nice.
30 Français ont été assassinés.
Nous devons faire
bloc et chérir
notre unité.
C'est le souhait
des députés républicains.
Les assauts viennent
de toutes parts.
Des terroristes
souhaitent détruire
nos valeurs,
en commençant nos valeurs.
Comment le gouvernement
de la France peut préserver
notre communauté
nationale
contre ceux qui veulent
la détruire?
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le député,
la France compte
la première communauté
juive d'Europe.
Elle compte la troisième
communauté juive
du monde.
La France protège
tous ses citoyens.
Elle s'est enrichie
par l'histoire.
Elle sait que s'en prendre
à des personnes
de confession juive,
c'est s'en prendre
à tous les Français.
Je sais que les Français
de confession juive prient
pour la République,
pour les policiers,
les gendarmes et les militaires.
Aujourd'hui, les policiers,
les gendarmes
et les militaires sont fiers
de protéger 900 lieux
en France,
où ils vont librement vivre
leur culte, amener
leurs enfants
dans des écoles
confessionnelles,
se balader
dans n'importe quel coin
du territoire,
qu'il s'agisse des quartiers
de la banlieue parisienne
ou de la province française,
parce que les policiers
et les gendarmes protègent jour
et nuit.
Ils sont plus de 10.000.
Cela explique,
malgré la grande peur,
qu'il n'y a pas eu,
comme dans d'autres pays,
des synagogues attaquées
par des cocktails Molotov.
Il y a eu plus de 400
interpellations
de personnes qui ont fait
des actes antisémites.
Nous leur retirons
systématiquement
leur titre de séjour.
Etre responsable
d'un acte antisémite,
porter une menace
antisémite,
c'est porter atteinte
à toute la République.
A tous les juifs
de France je veux dire
que leur peur est la nôtre
et la protection
de la République
sera, pour eux,
leur communauté.
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à monsieur Aymeric
Caron.
- Aymeric Caron: Merci.
Le 7 octobre dernier,
le Hamas s'est rendu coupable
de crimes ignobles
contre des civils israéliens.
Plus de 1400 personnes
ont été tuées
dans des circonstances
qui suscitent l'effroi,
l'indignation, le dégoût.
Aux crimes de guerre
du Hamas répondent
les crimes de guerre
de l'armée israélienne.
Les bombardements
sur Gaza auraient
fait près de 6000 morts,
parmi lesquels 2400 enfants.
On a l'impression
d'un deux poids,
deux mesures.
Dans cette Assemblée,
des voix manquent
encore pour dénoncer
le sort subi
par les Palestiniens,
comme si une vie palestinienne
valait moins qu'une
vie israélienne.
Plus grave encore,
la présidente
de cette Assemblée a voulu
réitérer l'expression
de son soutien inconditionnel
au gouvernement israélien
en se rendant sur place.
Lors de son déplacement,
elle a déclaré
qu'il fallait
préserver les civils
à Gaza, mais que rien
ne devait empêcher Israël
de se défendre.
Aujourd'hui,
la France doit demander
un cessez-le-feu immédiat.
Elle doit également
dénoncer la colonisation
et demander son arrêt.
C'est le seul moyen
de continuer à croire
en la solution à deux Etats.
Madame Premier ministre,
il nous semblait
que c'était le chemin
que la France commençait enfin
à choisir,
mais le président
de la République
n'a pas prononcé
ces mots tout à l'heure.
Il a proposé
que la coalition
contre l'Etat islamique
puisse lutter aussi
contre Hamas.
Quelles sont les implications
concrètes
de ses déclarations
pour la France?
Est-ce que ça veut dire
que la France renonce
à exiger un cessez-le-feu?
Est-ce que ça veut dire
que vous renoncez
à exiger le respect des droits
des Palestiniens?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Becht.
- Olivier Becht: Merci.
Depuis 17 jours,
La France Insoumise montre
son vrai visage,
celui de l'indignité
de pouvoir nommer
ce qu'est véritablement
le Hamas, c'est-à-dire
un mouvement terroriste.
Aucune cause ne justifie
que l'on assassine,
que l'on décapite,
que l'on brûle
des hommes, des femmes,
des enfants
et des bébés.
Ce que le président
Lula et le Conseil
de sécurité
au Brésil nomment,
vous n'êtes pas capable
de le faire,
vous ici.
La position de la France
est très claire.
Elle a été rappelée
par le président
de la République
et par la Première ministre.
Elle a été rappelée
par la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères,
qui est aujourd'hui
au Conseil de sécurité
à l'ONU.
Nous demandons
une trêve humanitaire
qui permette d'acheminer
l'aide humanitaire
que la France finance à hauteur
de 20 millions d'euros
pour les Palestiniens.
Nous avons appelé
à ce que cette trêve puisse amener
un cessez-le-feu.
Nous n'avons jamais
fait l'assimilation
entre le Hamas
et le peuple palestinien.
Le président
de la République se rend
en ce moment à Ramallah.
Nous défendons
une solution à deux Etats,
qui est la seule
solution qui permette
à deux peuples
de vivre côte
à côte et en paix.
La position de la France
est claire, contrairement
à la vôtre.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Aude Luquet.
- Aude Luquet: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
Agnès Pannier-Runacher.
Nos concitoyens,
nos industriels
et nos entreprises
ont lourdement été éprouvés
par la flambée des prix
de l'électricité
en 2022.
Face à cette crise,
le gouvernement
a été au rendez-vous
pour protéger
les Français comme nulle
part ailleurs
grâce à la mise en place
du bouclier tarifaire.
Une incompréhension
persiste vis-à-vis
des prix de l'électricité,
qui apparaissent
en déconnexion avec ceux
de notre production.
Il ne s'agit pas de remettre
en cause
la solidarité
européenne au travers
de notre marché
de l'électricité,
comme le propose
le Rassemblement National,
avec démagogie
et irresponsabilité.
Sans cette
solidarité,
nous n'aurions pas tenu
face à la crise.
Il s'agit
de défendre des prix
sur le long terme
pour modérer les factures
des ménages et des entreprises,
en limitant
le lien entre les prix
de l'électricité
et ceux du gaz.
Dans ce contexte,
la France a été
à l'avant-garde
de ce combat en défendant
une réforme du marché européen
de l'électricité.
C'est un succès
que nous pouvons saluer.
Cela a permis
de faire comprendre
à nos voisins allemands
que la compétitivité
des entreprises
nucléaires
était un avantage
pour tous les Européens.
La France a soutenu
une parole forte.
Cet accord européen
est une victoire française
dont nous pouvons être fiers.
C'est une victoire européenne.
Nous renforçons
notre compétitivité vis-à-vis
des Etats-Unis.
C'est une victoire
aussi pour le climat,
car cet accord facilitera
les investissements
dans la production
d'énergies décarbonées.
Pouvons-nous nous indiquer
les prochaines étapes
de négociation
et ce que peuvent espérer
les Français pour leurs prochaines
factures d'électricité?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci.
Madame la députée Luquet,
avec cet accord
sur le marché
de l'électricité,
la France obtient
une victoire majeure.
Comme vous l'avez
souligné,
c'est une victoire
de l'Europe,
qui affirme sa puissance
économique face
à la concurrence de la Chine
et à l'inflation
reduction act américain.
C'est une victoire
pour la France
et les Français,
avec un traitement identique
entre le nucléaire
et les énergies renouvelables.
C'est aussi une victoire
pour le climat,
parce que les
investissements
dans les énergies décarbonées
seront facilités.
C'est aussi la victoire
du bon sens
et de la raison.
Une victoire face
à l'extrême droite
et à l'extrême gauche,
qui n'ont cessé
de prôner la sortie
du marché européen.
A quoi aurait
mené le projet
que vous avez proposé
la semaine dernière
dans votre proposition
largement décriée
sur l'ensemble de ces bancs?
A augmenter massivement
la facture d'électricité
des Français, à mettre
en grave difficulté
les industriels
et à porter atteinte
à notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement...
Avec cet accord,
nous déconnectons
les prix du gaz
et de l'électricité.
Nous empêchons
l'envolée des prix
de l'électricité.
Nous stabilisons les prix
de l'électricité
sur le long terme
pour les industriels
et les Français.
Nous sécurisons
notre approvisionnement.
Voilà, en d'autres termes,
nous reprenons
le contrôle sur le prix
de l'électricité.
Cet accord est le fruit
de la vision
et de l'exigence
que porte le président
de la République
pour l'Union Européenne.
Le travail que j'ai mené
avec l'Alliance européenne
pour le nucléaire
et avec la Commission européenne
a payé.
Cette étape
est maintenant franchie.
Nous tiendrons la promesse
présidentielle.
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à madame Christelle
Petex-Levet.
- Christelle Petex-Levet: Merci.
Nos entreprises
françaises sont en danger
et vous êtes si peu inquiet.
La situation savoyarde
est le reflet
de ce qui se passe
partout ailleurs
dans le pays.
Des entreprises
volontaires et pourtant
à bout, anxieuses
de l'avenir dicté
par des contraintes étatiques
qui s'accumulent.
Tout d'abord, l'énergie,
la fin annoncée
de l'amortisseur
électricité
pour les entreprises
déjà en difficulté,
comment faire face
à des factures exorbitantes?
Le monde entier
sait que la France
a des tarifs d'énergie
des plus élevés.
Des industriels perdent
tous leurs clients
au profit de la concurrence
étrangère.
La prévention
de la gestion des déchets,
avec les fameuses REP.
Inflation des taux
d'écocontribution,
inégalité de traitement
ou distorsion
de concurrence
avec les produits importés.
Ce dispositif,
à l'instar de contribuer
à remplir les objectifs
de décarbonation
et d'instaurer
des conditions loyales
pour le marché,
se révèle être pénalisant
et inéquitable.
Autre exemple, le ZAN,
zéro artificialisation nette.
Quand allez-vous
prendre conscience
de l'ampleur de la situation?
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à Roland Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci.
Si j'ai bien
un acharnement,
c'est de m'assurer
que l'industrie française
va sortir gagnante
de toutes les crises auxquelles
on fait face
et des opportunités
qui se présentent.
Ce combat, le jour
où le président
de la République
a promulgué le projet
de loi d'industrie
verte,
qui a fait l'objet
d'un très large consensus,
je suis heureux
de voir que la plupart
des députés sont prêts
aussi à le mener
à nos côtés.
Vous avez mentionné
la crise énergétique.
La France a protégé
ses industries
comme personne au monde.
J'étais aujourd'hui
à la journée
de l'industrie automobile.
Tout le monde y a reconnu
que l'industrie automobile
a été résiliente
dans cette crise,
et c'est grâce à nous.
Vous avez mentionné
les filières REP,
l'objectif majeur
qui est de développer
une industrie circulaire
pour être capable
de concilier industrie
et écologie.
Vendredi,
nous avons fêté les 60 ans
de la cocotte-minute à Dijon.
L'industrie française
est prête à épouser
cette grande cause
de la durabilité
et de l'industrie écologique.
Il faut
nous rassembler
autour de ce bon combat.
Nous sommes capables
de réindustrialiser
la France.
Nous sommes capables
de le faire
en la verdissant.
Rejoignez-nous,
soutenez-nous, soutenons
les entreprises françaises.
Merci.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
Madame la députée?
- Christelle
Petex-Levet: J'en
suis convaincue.
Maintenant, agissons
en conséquence.
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à madame Alexandra
Martin.
- Alexandra Martin: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur Gabriel Attal,
ministre de l'Education
nationale
et de la Jeunesse.
Aux professeurs,
enseignants, instituteurs,
directeurs d'école
et à l'ensemble
du personnel éducatif,
à vous témoigner
de toute ma solidarité.
Dans notre histoire
personnelle,
il existera toujours
un professeur
qui nous a marqué
le coeur et l'esprit,
qui nous a donné
l'envie de nous élever
et de nous dépasser.
Nous sommes nombreux
à nous souvenir
et à partager ces anecdotes
des années collège
et lycée.
J'ai une pensée
pour ma professeur
de français,
qui m'a transmis l'amour
de la littérature
et le goût de l'effort.
L'un comme l'autre
ne m'ont jamais quittée.
L'école est un lieu
d'apprentissage,
d'autonomie et d'émancipation.
L'école est un lieu où on peut
se construire indépendamment
de toute influence extérieure.
Comme disait Jean Jaurès
dans sa lettre
aux instituteurs,
c'est le lieu
où on peut
être mis en état
par une éducation
libre de juger
toutes les croyances.
Cette liberté
est aujourd'hui menacée.
Chaque jour, des professeurs
craignent d'aller enseigner.
Chaque jour,
des parents s'inquiètent.
Le climat dans lequel
est plongée
notre école n'est plus acceptable.
La peur doit changer de camp.
Nous avons déclenché
le plan attentat,
mais ce besoin
de sécurité
est plus profond et exige
une réponse durable.
Notre école doit
redevenir un lieu
de paix et de sérénité.
Pour y parvenir,
nous devons travailler
avec tous les acteurs concernés.
Monsieur le ministre,
comment le gouvernement
compte-t-il, en associant
les collectivités territoriales,
répondre à ce besoin
urgent de sécurité?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Je veux vous remercier
pour les mots
que vous avez eus
pour l'école
et nos enseignants.
Je vous remercie
aussi pour la phrase
de Jean Jaurès
que vous avez citée.
Je répondrai en disant que l'école
doit rester l'asile inviolable
où les querelles
des hommes n'entrent pas.
Cette phrase dit
tout le besoin de sérénité
que nous avons à l'école.
Il n'y a pas de sérénité
sans sécurité.
Nos enseignants,
nos élèves, les familles,
ont besoin
d'être rassurés
sur leur sécurité
quand ils se rendent
à l'école.
On dit souvent que l'école
est un sanctuaire,
ça veut dire
que l'on doit toujours
être plus en sécurité
dans l'école qu'en dehors
de l'école.
Vous l'avez dit,
les collectivités locales
sont chargées
des bâtiments scolaires
et de la sécurité
de ces bâtiments.
J'ai réuni
les associations d'élus
le 18 octobre dernier.
Nous avons publié
une déclaration commune
à l'issue de cette réunion.
Qu'est-ce que nous avons dit?
D'abord, que beaucoup
d'investissements
ont été réalisés,
notamment depuis 2015,
pour renforcer la sécurité
des établissements scolaires.
Il faut aussi
continuer à aller
plus loin.
J'ai déclenché
une enquête Slash
sur tous les établissements
scolaires
pour mesurer le niveau actuel.
Nous nous reverrons
dans les prochains jours
avec l'ensemble
des associations d'élus
pour s'accorder
sur les mesures essentielles
pour continuer
à aller plus loin
dans le renforcement
de la sécurité.
La règle
est claire:
on ne doit pas pouvoir
pénétrer
dans un établissement
scolaire
quand on n'a rien à y faire.
Si c'est le cas,
il faut que les personnels soient
formés pour y réagir.
Depuis 2017, nous avons consacré
100 millions d'euros
de l'Etat pour accompagner
les collectivités.
Nous continuerons.
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à Frédéric
Boccaletti.
- Frédéric Boccaletti:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Pour débattre de l'hôpital public,
il y a normalement
le projet de loi
de financement
de la Sécurité sociale.
Mais il n'y aura pas de débat.
La Première ministre
va à nouveau mépriser
les Français avec un nouveau 49.3.
Vous n'écoutez pas
non plus le personnel soignant.
En 2017, le rapport
du Sénat alertait
sur les conséquences
des fermetures
de lits, mais le gouvernement
a continué
à en fermer.
Il faut sanctuariser le budget
de l'hôpital public
à un niveau conséquent.
Le personnel
soignant en maladie
n'est pas remplacé.
On accumule les semaines
de 60 heures.
Il y a des fermetures
des urgences.
Le service des urgences
de Brignoles
va perdre des médecins.
Des patients restent
jusqu'à 10 jours
aux urgences par manque de lits.
Si une crise advenait,
nous serions incapables
d'y faire face.
Le 13 octobre,
la quasi-totalité
du personnel
était en arrêt maladie
dans un hôpital.
Ils sont épuisés.
Si l'hôpital va mal,
les services d'urgence
sont à l'agonie.
Quand allez-vous mettre
les moyens humains
et financiers pour sauver
l'hôpital public?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Agnès Firmin
Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Merci.
Vous m'interrogez
sur la situation
des urgences
et sur la situation
de tension
que nous connaissons
dans le Var.
Nous avons connu
un été très difficile
pour le système de santé.
Je souligne ici
l'engagement
de tous les professionnels
de santé.
Le travail avec les élus
locaux a permis
La situation
la plus délicate
est celle des urgences
de Toulon,
où un mouvement
spontané a conduit
de nombreux
professionnels de santé
à se mettre en arrêt de travail.
Le dialogue a été renoué.
Cela a permis une reprise
de l'activité.
Avec Aurélien
Rousseau,
nous sommes attentifs
aux conclusions
de la concertation
qui sera menée
par les professionnels de santé.
Je rappelle
à quel point le travail
de fond engagé
sur la question de l'hôpital
et des urgences est essentiel.
Les difficultés
sont réelles
et les urgences
ne sont que le symptôme
de problèmes bien plus profonds.
C'est pourquoi
la question des urgences
a fait l'objet de décisions
très importantes
depuis juillet 2022.
Un soutien aux personnels
travaillant
dans les services,
des organisations innovantes
travaillaient
avec les acteurs,
de nouvelles
complémentarités
entre les professionnels de santé.
Notre préoccupation
est le bon fonctionnement
des urgences.
Il faut rouvrir
des lits,
mais pour cela,
il faut des professionnels
de santé qui travaillent.
Les services de l'Etat
et du gouvernement
sont pleinement mobilisés.
- Frédéric Boccaletti:
Vos propos
ne sont pas
convaincants
et ne sont pas au niveau
de ce qu'attendent
les soignants.
Cela n'est pas étonnant.
Le ministre de la Santé
est un ancien directeur
de l'ARS.
L'hôpital public
est au fond du trou
et vous continuez
à creuser
encore et encore.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Perceval Gaillard.
- Perceval Gaillard: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer,
une de mes communes
à la Réunion est soumise
à des restrictions d'eau.
Le mois dernier,
je suis allé à la rencontre
des habitants privés
d'eau potable
depuis 40 ans.
Il y a 200 personnes
qui survivent
avec l'eau croupie,
des retenues collinaires
et quelques bouteilles
d'eau acheminées.
Comment cela est-il
possible en 2023,
70 ans après que La Réunion
soit devenue
un département?
Nous voulons le soutien de l'Etat.
La question
de l'eau se pose
dans les territoires
transocéaniques
après des années
de sous-investissements.
A Mayotte, la situation est pire
maintenant qu'avant
la départementalisation.
Vous faites le lien
entre votre obsession,
l'immigration,
et la crise de l'eau.
Notre peuple
mérite mieux
que d'être l'otage
de ce genre de sujet.
Il faut choisir
"entre le champagne
pour quelques-uns
et l'eau potable
pour tous".
Prenez-vous ici
l'engagement de mettre
en place un plan
d'investissement massif
dans nos infrastructures
d'acheminement d'eau?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Monsieur le député,
vous avez raison.
Dans les outre-mer
et singulièrement
dans l'océan Indien,
il y a des difficultés d'accès
à l'eau.
Le phénomène touche
particulièrement l'océan Indien
et Mayotte, et aussi la Réunion.
Ce n'est pas de la faute
de l'Etat.
Si votre question
est que l'Etat reprenne
la main sur un certain nombre
de dispositifs locaux,
nous y sommes prêts.
En Guadeloupe, 320
millions d'euros
ont été investis.
La question est en train
d'être réglée
par le travail important
d'investissement
de l'Etat.
Le ministre des Outre-mer
ira prochainement
à La Réunion
afin de discuter
du fait que l'Etat
puisse reprendre
la main sur une partie
des compétences
et des dispositifs.
Les fuites
sont nombreuses
dans les réseaux d'eau.
Il faut faire
en sorte
que tous les citoyens
de notre pays puissent
avoir de l'eau
potable et courante.
Ceci n'est pas encore le cas
aujourd'hui.
Il faut donner
aux collectivités locales
les moyens de le faire.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
Monsieur le député?
- Perceval Gaillard:
Après les paroles,
nous attendons les actes.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Jacques Gaultier.
- Jean-Jacques Gaultier:
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
de la Culture.
Elle concerne les missions
et le financement
de l'audiovisuel public,
qui représente 4 milliards d'euros
par an pour les Français
et qui nécessitent donc
transparence,
évaluation et contrôle.
L'audiovisuel public
a un rôle central face
à la désinformation.
Il a aussi un rôle central
pour la culture,
pour notre économie en matière
de droits d'auteur
ou de fiction française,
par exemple.
Il faut réaffirmer
plus clairement
ses différences
avec les chaînes privées.
D'abord, sur les missions.
L'Arcom a rendu un avis assez
critique jugeant insuffisante
l'offre de culture
sur France 2 et France 3.
Est-il normal
que l'audience de France 4
ne soit plus mesurée, d'ailleurs?
Il est important que l'on puisse
contrôler l'exercice
de ces missions de service public.
Différence de financement
également,
puisque dans un marché
publicitaire global
qui baisse ou stagne,
ou qui se déporte
vers le numérique,
les recettes publicitaires
de France Télévisions
ont augmenté
de 2018 à 2022.
C'est une exception en Europe.
Partout ailleurs,
il n'y a pas de publicité
sur l'audiovisuel public.
C'est aussi une sorte
de détournement
de l'esprit de la loi
de 2009 qui supprimait
la publicité après 20h.
Comment comptez-vous
contrôler la publicité
sur le service
public
et est-ce que le gouvernement
est favorable
à la proposition de loi
transpartisane visant
à pérenniser le financement
de l'audiovisuel public
après 2024?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Rima Abdul-Malak.
- Rima Abdul-Malak: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
merci de votre engagement
sur ce sujet.
Pour travailler
sur cette trajectoire
pluriannuelle sur cinq ans
qui est proposée
aux entreprises de l'audiovisuel
public jusqu'en 2028,
nous nous sommes appuyés
en grande partie
sur les propositions
formulées
lors de votre mission
d'information.
Je pense qu'on partage
les constats
que vous avez soulevés,
ainsi que les constats soulevés
par l'Arcom
sur un vieillissement
de l'audience.
Il faut préserver
la place de la création,
de l'accès à la culture,
mais aussi
le rôle d'éducation
aux médias
de ces chaînes
et de ses programmes.
Il y a aussi un enjeu
de proximité, accéléré
avec le rapprochement
entre France 3
et France Bleu.
Il y a une nouveauté
dans la trajectoire financière
que nous présentons,
c'est d'avoir une dotation
de base
pour les entreprises,
comme précédemment,
mais aussi une enveloppe
complémentaire
qui sera actionnée
au fur et à mesure
de l'accélération
des transformations
et de la modernisation
des projets prioritaires,
qui sera réservée
sur les trois années,
de 2024 à 2026,
aux enjeux prioritaires
que vous mentionnez.
Nous voulons un audiovisuel
public fort,
qui respecte la parité
de l'information,
qui lutte
contre la désinformation
et qui touche plus la jeunesse.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
Monsieur le député?
- Jean-Jacques Gaultier:
J'espère
que le gouvernement
fera preuve
de la même réactivité
que le Parlement.
Le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale
ont travaillé ensemble
et de manière transpartisane.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Jacqueline Maquet.
- Jacqueline Maquet:
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre
du Logement.
Le logement est essentiel
à la dignité humaine,
et se trouve au centre
de la préoccupation
de nos concitoyens.
Il constitue
un pilier fondamental
de notre société.
Il est également
un levier indispensable
de notre transition écologique.
La situation
du logement en France
est préoccupante.
Nous sommes confrontés
à une crise marquée
par des difficultés
structurelles telles
que ladite diminution
du foncier disponible,
la baisse des permis
de construire, etc.
Tout ceci est exacerbé
par une crise conjoncturelle liée
à la hausse rapide
des taux d'intérêt.
Des efforts ont été déployés
pour augmenter l'offre,
soutenir les plus modestes
et mettre
en place une stratégie
de rénovation énergétique
à grande échelle.
Plusieurs mesures,
telles que le développement
du locatif intermédiaire,
la refonte
de la fiscalité locative
ou le renforcement
de la garantie Visale
vont dans la bonne direction,
mais sont insuffisantes.
Précisez-nous
votre vision
et votre stratégie
pour accélérer
la résolution
du conflit du logement
en France.
Comment mobiliser
et coordonner
les efforts des collectivités,
des promoteurs,
des bailleurs, des aménageurs
pour concrétiser
cette vision et répondre
de manière efficace
aux besoins
pressants en matière
de logement?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est au ministre
délégué chargé
du Logement.
- Patrice Vergriete:
Madame la présidente,
madame la députée
Jacqueline Maquet.
Nous vivons une crise
de la production
du logement,
avec une baisse d'un tiers
des permis de construire
d'ici la fin
de l'année.
Cette crise s'explique
en grande partie
par la forte hausse
des taux d'intérêt
dans un contexte
de rareté foncière.
Le gouvernement y répond
avec détermination.
D'abord, à travers
une série de mesures
à caractère économique,
pour aider
nos concitoyens
et pour équilibrer
les opérations
de construction de logements.
C'est le sens
de l'élargissement
du prêt à taux zéro,
particulièrement incitatif
en ce moment.
C'est le sens du soutien
au logement locatif intermédiaire,
en faveur du logement
locatif social,
qui a donné lieu
à un accord à Nantes
au congrès des HLM.
Au-delà de ces mesures,
le gouvernement engagera également
des actions plus fortes
et plus ciblées
sur les territoires
qui en ont le plus besoin.
Un programme vise
à accélérer la production
de logements dans la vingtaine
d'agglomérations
où la pénurie
est la plus forte aujourd'hui,
à travers des mesures
financières,
mais aussi réglementaires.
Nous avons réussi
à accélérer la production
de logements
pour les JO de Paris,
nous pouvons aussi
le faire pour répondre
à la crise du logement.
Au regard des retours
des élus locaux,
ce sur-mesure plaît
aux collectivités locales
et donne lieu à un programme
très intéressant.
Le gouvernement répond donc
avec détermination
à cette crise du logement.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Paul Lecoq.
- Jean-Paul Lecoq: Merci.
Chers collègues,
depuis l'agression terroriste
du Hamas en Israël,
plutôt que de réagir
par le droit et la justice,
le gouvernement israélien
se déchaîne contre la population
palestinienne.
Le blocus total de Gaza
et les bombardements
ont tué des milliers d'innocents.
En Cisjordanie,
dans Jérusalem occupée,
la situation continue.
Plus de 90 Palestiniens
y ont été tués
par l'armée et les colons
en deux semaines.
Beaucoup
de Palestiniens arabes
ont été expulsés
de chez eux en représailles.
Des campements sont assiégés
par l'armée israélienne.
C'est indigne d'une démocratie.
Le peuple palestinien
n'est pas responsable
des horreurs du Hamas.
Alors que le conflit
déborde
dans les pays arabes voisins,
la France, membre
du Conseil de sécurité
des Nations Unies,
doit poser en urgence
des actes forts afin
de trouver
au plus vite le chemin
de la paix.
Le corridor et les moyens
humanitaires
ne sont qu'une
goutte d'eau
pour la population.
La France doit
obtenir au plus vite
un cessez-le-feu
permettant d'obtenir
la libération des otages.
Cela entamera une ère
nouvelle de négociations
de paix en tenant
compte des leçons
de l'histoire.
Ce cessez-le-feu
ne peut conduire
à un statu quo.
Il doit conduire
à un accord de paix.
Les pacifistes
le réclament
depuis des années
et proposent des solutions
à mettre en oeuvre rapidement.
Les paroles
des bellicistes n'ont
fait qu'empirer le drame.
Seuls les morts font
malheureusement réagir.
En 2014,
notre Assemblée a voté
une résolution visant
une reconnaissance
par la France
de l'Etat palestinien.
Près de 10 ans plus tard,
il est temps d'y accéder.
Le président de la République
semble enfin
y être prêt.
Si la France osait
un acte diplomatique
de cette ampleur,
quel message magnifique
et utile pour la paix!
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est au ministre
délégué chargé
du Commerce extérieur.
- Olivier Becht:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le député Jean-Paul Lecoq.
Si la ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères
est absente, c'est parce
qu'elle est précisément
au Conseil
de sécurité
et que nous y défendons
depuis plus d'une semaine
la question de la trêve
humanitaire
qui doit déboucher
sur un cessez-le-feu
à terme.
La France a condamné
avec la plus grande fermeté
les attaques terroristes du Hamas.
Nous avons soutenu
le droit d'Israël
à se défendre et à répliquer
de manière légitime,
dans le respect
du droit international,
du droit de la guerre
et dans le respect
du droit humanitaire.
Nous sommes au soutien
du peuple palestinien
à travers les aides humanitaires.
20 millions d'euros
ont déjà été engagés.
S'il faut allonger
ce montant,
nous sommes prêts à le faire.
En ce qui concerne
la position
de la France, elle est claire.
Elle est claire depuis 30 ans.
Nous avons soutenu,
depuis les accords d'Oslo,
la solution qui permet
au peuple palestinien
et au peuple israélien
de vivre en paix
côte à côte.
La position
de la France est claire
et elle n'a pas varié.
Le président de la République
l'a rappelé aujourd'hui
à Tel-Aviv, à Jérusalem
et à Ramallah.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan.
- Nicolas Dupont-Aignan: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre.
Mardi dernier,
nous étions tous rassemblés
avec émotion pour rendre hommage
à Dominique Bernard,
victime du terrorisme islamique.
J'ai bien écouté la réponse
de la Première ministre
et je n'ai noté
que deux annonces concrètes:
le resserrage
du plan Vigipirate
et le recyclage
du projet immigration.
Rien sur le rétablissement
des frontières nationales,
seul moyen d'empêcher
l'infiltration
de nouveaux terroristes.
Rien
non plus dans vos propos
sur une refonte
complète de l'examen
du droit d'asile
dans des centres fermés,
aux frontières,
pour éviter
que les déboutés
restent sur notre sol.
Rien
non plus dans vos propos
sur un référendum
pour revenir
à la primauté
du droit national
sur le maquis
des jurisprudences
et des directives
de l'Union Européenne
qui paralyse notre pays.
Rien
non plus dans vos propos
sur la suppression
des aides
et des visas pour les pays
qui empêchent l'exécution
des OQTF.
Rien sur la fin
de votre politique folle
de rapatriement des femmes
de l'Etat djihadiste.
Il y en a 80
dans nos prisons
qui vont sortir bientôt.
Après tant de victimes
du terrorisme
dans notre pays,
quand allez-vous passer
des discours creux,
des gesticulations,
au rétablissement
de notre souveraineté nationale
pour protéger nos concitoyens?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin...
Pardon, à monsieur
le garde des Sceaux.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci.
Qui a créé le parquet
national antiterroriste?
Qui a fait un renforcement
pénitentiaire?
Qui a créé les quartiers
d'évaluation
de la radicalisation?
Qui a créé les quartiers
de déradicalisation?
Qui a voté la loi séparatisme?
Où étiez-vous, monsieur le député?
Qui a renforcé
le nombre de policiers
et de magistrats dans ce pays?
Vous étiez trop occupés,
avec vos camarades Bigard
et les autres, à nous dire
que le vaccin tuait
nos compatriotes!
Vous ne représentez que vous-même!
Où étiez-vous
pour nous dire
que nous avons évité
343 attentats?
La justice antiterroriste
a parfaitement fonctionné
dans ce pays.
Vous surfez
sur les morts,
comme vous avez surfé
sur les malades.
- Valérie Rabault:
Monsieur le député?
- Nicolas Dupont-Aignan:
Votre réponse
est une insulte
aux millions de Français
qui se font du souci
pour leur sécurité.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Christine Arrighi.
- Christine Arrighi: Merci.
Cette question
de deux minutes,
le temps de la démocratie
du mardi, s'adresse
à Clément Beaune.
Monsieur Gabriel
Attal,
puisque vous êtes présent,
je pose
une alerte.
La France ne sait plus compter...
Je m'adresse à vous,
monsieur Gabriel Attal.
Samedi, entre 9
et 10.000 manifestants
dans le Tarn.
Clément Beaune en annonce 2400.
Une cinquantaine
de personnes masquées
s'en prennent
à une entreprise,
action heureusement
circonscrite
par les forces de l'ordre
que l'on remercie.
Je pousse un cri
d'interpellation
à madame Retailleau.
Le gouvernement
a délogé dimanche
à coups de gaz
lacrymogènes
dans un champ prêté
par un agriculteur
des manifestants pacifistes.
Une démocratie qui relativise
les savoirs scientifiques,
voilà ce que nous sommes.
L'Etat choisit de donner
la concession autoroutière
à deux sociétés de droit
luxembourgeois.
Pendant ce temps,
l'Etat a consenti
un contrat de 55 ans
avec une société.
Pourriez-vous
nous dire pourquoi
une si longue durée?
Pouvez-vous également
nous confirmer qu'à l'aune
des formules
mathématiques figurant
dans le contrat,
le tarif pour 53 kilomètres
ne serait déjà
plus de 6,80 euros,
mais de 7,90 euros,
auxquels il faut rajouter
1,70 euro pour arriver
à Toulouse
par l'A68?
L'aller-retour
revient à 100 euros
par semaine!
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Clément Beaune.
- Clément Beaune:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés, madame
la députée Christine Arrighi.
Tout à votre complotiste
et à votre humour noir,
je regrette
que vous n'ayez pas commencé
par le commencement,
c'est-à-dire
par les principes
républicains
les plus élémentaires.
Vous n'avez pas condamné
les violences inacceptables
qui ont eu lieu.
Ceci n'est pas une question
d'arithmétique,
à part celle
des sept gendarmes
qui ont été blessés
par des violences scandaleuses.
Je regrette
que vous n'ayez pas commencé
par saluer l'action
des agents de l'Etat,
du préfet du Tarn
et des forces de police,
qui font respecter
l'ordre républicain.
Je regrette
que vous n'ayez pas eu
un mot pour rappeler
le nécessaire respect
du droit de manifester
dans le cadre
de la République
et de l'ordre nécessaire.
Ce n'est pas une question
d'arithmétique,
c'est une question de démocratie.
Je regrette
que vous n'ayez pas eu
un mot pour condamner.
Vous cautionnez
de fait ces violences.
Quel que soit le nombre
exact,
il y a eu
des centaines et même
des milliers
d'individus radicalisés
qui ont incendié,
vrai ou pas vrai?
Madame Rousseau a porté
loin l'indécence
en défendant
le port de couteaux
et de pioches.
Vous avez le droit
d'être contre
un projet.
Nous en avons discuté longuement.
Vous avez le droit
d'encourager et de participer
à des manifestations,
mais pas d'oublier
le respect des principes
républicains élémentaires.
La discussion
a toujours été ouverte.
Nous en avons discuté des heures.
Il faut d'abord respecter
les principes nécessaires
de notre démocratie
et notre Etat
de droit.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
Madame Christine Arrighi?
Il ne vous reste
plus de temps de parole.
Vous n'avez
Il ne reste
plus de temps de parole
à madame Arrighi.
La parole est à monsieur
Alain David.
- Alain David: Merci.
Madame la Première
ministre, au moment
où vous avez déclenché le premier
d'une longue série
de 49.3, où vous avez créé
un paradis fiscal
pour la FIFA,
en rejetant simultanément
des amendements
adoptés en commission,
l'austérité
dans laquelle
vous vous enfermez
continue à produire
ses effets dévastateurs.
Vous ne prévoyez rien,
ni pour les anciens
ni pour les jeunes,
sur lesquels
je vais me concentrer.
Dans ma circonscription
et partout
en France, on constate
que les jeunes,
qu'ils soient étudiants,
apprentis, vivent
de plus en plus sous le seuil
de pauvreté.
Cette précarité
nous affecte
de plus en plus sur tous
les pans
de leur vie: le logement,
la santé, l'alimentation.
Comment peuvent-ils
poursuivre sereinement
leurs études
ou l'apprentissage
d'un métier?
Comment se projeter
dans la vie
quand on ne côtoie
que la galère,
pour ne pas dire la misère?
Une tribune publiée
dans le journal Le Monde
a évoqué il y a peu
un revenu universel.
Madame la Première ministre,
l'urgence sociale
est grande.
De nombreuses
familles en appellent
aux associations d'entraide
ou aux collectivités locales.
L'Etat ne peut
plus être absent face
à cette précarité grandissante.
Vos choix
budgétaires
ne peuvent pas continuer
à favoriser outrageusement
les plus nantis,
des mesures d'urgence doivent
rapidement être prises
à la mesure
de la détresse de la jeunesse.
Merci.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
Allez-y, madame la ministre.
- Merci.
A force de crier
dans cet hémicycle,
vous oubliez ce qui s'est passé.
Si aujourd'hui
je suis assise en bas
de ces bancs,
j'ai été pendant un an
à côté de vous.
Je peux vous dire qu'il est assez
savoureux d'entendre qu'encore
aujourd'hui,
vous niez l'effort
qui est fait
par cette majorité
depuis 2017.
Prenez des notes.
Nous avons favorisé
l'apprentissage.
l'emploi des jeunes
comme jamais.
Nous avons permis
aujourd'hui,
avec le ministre
Olivier Dussopt,
de signer le 500.000e contrat
d'engagement jeune.
500.000 jeunes
ont été accompagnés
dans l'insertion.
Vous parliez des jeunes étudiants.
Qui a permis
de permettre la création
du repas à 1 euro?
C'est nous.
Qui a pérennisé
ce système
pour les plus précaires
et les élèves boursiers?
C'est nous.
Qui a gelé le loyer des CROUS?
Etre assis à gauche
de l'hémicycle,
c'est bien,
mais en porter les valeurs,
c'est mieux.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
Monsieur le député?
- Alain David:
Madame la ministre,
j'ai noté que tout allait
bien finalement...
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à Antoine Armand.
- Antoine Armand: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
Agnès Pannier-Runacher.
Le 17 octobre dernier,
vous avez obtenu
un accord historique
au Conseil européen
sur la réforme
du marché européen
de l'électricité.
Nous le savons tous
ici, les règles
du marché définies
ces dernières années
ont pénalisé
la France
et tout notre continent
dans la transition énergétique.
Nous étions nombreux
sur ces bancs
à en demander
une réforme profonde,
une réforme et non
une sortie absurde
et dangereuse.
Nous avons besoin...
Nous l'avions fait
de manière transpartisane
dans la commission
d'enquête parlementaire
dont j'ai eu l'honneur
d'être le rapporteur.
Nous l'avons porté ensemble.
Vous avez obtenu
cet accord
grâce à l'alliance
des pays du nucléaire.
Quel contraste
avec les démagogies
de certains dans cet hémicycle!
On avait les créatifs
au Parti Socialiste
et leurs alliés
de la NUPES,
ceux qui voulaient
nationaliser
une entreprise
qui était déjà détenue
à 100% par l'Etat, bravo!
Nous avions les grands réactifs
au Rassemblement National,
tellement réactifs
qu'ils voulaient supprimer
un dispositif
dont on négociait déjà
la sortie et le successeur, bravo!
Ce qui compte,
c'est d'avoir maintenant
la loi de production
annoncée
par le président de la République.
Je vous demande
quelles sont les prochaines
échéances et orientations.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher:
Oui, je travaille,
monsieur le député.
Merci.
Permettez-moi,
avant de vous répondre,
de paraphraser le président
de la République.
Tout le monde nous disait
que c'était impossible,
mais nous l'avons
fait,
parce qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas
la France
et l'Europe,
ils ne connaissaient pas
la détermination
de cette majorité
à réformer le système
du marché de l'électricité
et à reprendre
notre destin énergétique en main.
Ils ne connaissaient pas
notre détermination
à obtenir de la Commission
européenne
et de notre voisin
allemand un accord
qui soit favorable
aux Français
et aux Européens.
Cette détermination
pour bâtir
notre souveraineté
et notre compétitivité
et surtout pour répondre
au défi
de ce siècle: sortir
des énergies fossiles
pour mieux lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique.
Nous avons tenu nos promesses.
Nous avons déconnecté le prix
de l'électricité
du prix de gaz.
Nous avons obtenu
la reconnaissance
du nucléaire
et nous reprenons le contrôle
des prix de l'électricité.
Cet accord marque
donc un tournant
pour la France.
Il renforce la position
de la France
en Europe.
Il est le résultat
d'efforts acharnés
et il n'a pas été
simple à obtenir.
Il est le résultat
du volontarisme
du président
de la République
et de l'ensemble des équipes
qui l'ont négocié.
C'est la meilleure réponse
à la concurrence chinoise.
à l'extrême droite
et à l'extrême gauche,
qui n'ont cessé
de prôner le repli
sur soi avec la sortie
du marché européen.
Maintenant que cet
accord est en place,
nous nous tournons
vers l'avenir
avec la loi de production
énergétique,
à laquelle
vous avez contribué
dans cet hémicycle.
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à Florence Goulet.
- Florence Goulet: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
de la Transition énergétique.
Mardi 17 octobre
dernier, un accord
a été conclu entre les Etats
de l'Union Européenne
sur la réforme du marché
de l'électricité,
et le gouvernement se félicite
d'une victoire française.
Pourtant, il n'y
a pas lieu de se réjouir,
car les factures
énergétiques des ménages
et des entreprises
ne baisseront pas.
Cet accord
témoigne une fois
de plus du renoncement
du gouvernement
à défendre les intérêts
de la France
et des Français.
Dans notre pays,
nous sommes passés,
en quelques années,
d'une vision d'avant-garde,
portée par le général
de Gaulle
et Georges Pompidou,
à un choix idéologique
catastrophique,
sous couvert d'un mythique couple
franco-allemand,
qui n'existe
que dans les couloirs de Bercy.
Le prix de l'électricité
française reste indexé
sur le prix européen du gaz.
Les prix
dérogatoires
ne concernent pas
les ménages
ni la grande majorité
des entreprises.
La France va rester privée
de la compétitivité
que lui offre
son parc nucléaire
et hydraulique existant.
Les prix énergétiques
à moyen et long terme
vont continuer
d'augmenter, d'autant
plus que vous supprimez
progressivement
le bouclier tarifaire.
La compétitivité
du nucléaire ne bénéficiera
qu'aux producteurs d'énergie.
Autrement dit, rien ne change.
Votre gouvernement
nous laisse pieds
et poings liés
aux dogmes européens
de la concurrence,
le tout restant
sous le contrôle
de la Commission européenne.
Madame la ministre,
pourquoi
ne voulez-vous pas
vous libérer
des règles absurdes
du marché européen
de l'énergie et remplacer
le système actuel
des prix par un prix français
de l'électricité?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci.
Quand l'Europe gagne,
c'est les Français
qui gagnent
et c'est le Rassemblement National
qui recule.
Vous vouliez sortir
du marché européen
et sortir de l'Europe tout court.
Nous vous opposons
la solidarité européenne,
celle qui a garanti
notre approvisionnement
en électricité
l'hiver dernier,
là où vous préféreriez
mettre les Français
dans le noir.
Vous en avez fait
le réceptacle
de votre détestation
de l'Europe,
au détriment de la facture
des Français
et des industriels et d'EDF.
Nous vous opposons
un accord historique,
qui est une victoire
pour l'Europe,
la France,
le nucléaire, le climat
et les Français.
Vous avez jeté
toutes vos forces
dans la bataille
pour nous faire croire
que l'Europe
était responsable
de la crise énergétique.
Madame la députée,
nous vous renvoyons
aux vrais responsables,
vos amis russes,
qui ont envahi l'Ukraine.
Marine Le Pen n'a
cessé de porter
une position
de repli mortifère
pour notre pays,
que même vos amis hongrois
et italiens ne suivent pas.
Nous vous opposons
le succès diplomatique,
qui est le fruit d'une politique
volontariste européenne,
car qu'ont fait
Marine Le Pen
et le Rassemblement National
pour défendre
les Français?
Rien.
Avez-vous augmenté
les boucliers énergétiques?
Non.
Vous avez rejeté
chacun des dispositifs
de protection
des Français permettant
de leur faire
bénéficier des prix
parmi les plus bas d'Europe.
Vous avez même porté
une proposition
de loi insensée,
qui aurait conduit
à l'augmentation brutale des prix.
Pendant que votre parti
prospère
sur les difficultés
des Français,
nous leur apportons
des réponses concrètes...
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Naegelen.
- Christophe Naegelen: Merci.
Notre système de santé
est en crise, notamment
dans les territoires ruraux.
Malgré le manque
de moyens, le manque
de personnels,
toutes les équipes
d'un hôpital
que je connais bien
sont extrêmement mobilisées
et engagées auprès
de leurs patients.
A la suite de récents
incidents,
la crise que traverse
cet hôpital s'est
encore intensifiée.
Monsieur le ministre,
c'est bien
d'un manque de moyens
que nos hôpitaux publics
souffrent.
Il faut recruter
plus de personnels
et considérer davantage
le personnel soignant
en place.
Ils sont les premiers
maillons
de la chaîne
de soins
et les plus à même
de faire remonter
les problématiques de terrain.
Que comptez-vous
faire pour venir
en aide à cet hôpital,
qui dans sa globalité
est largement
éprouvé
par tout ce qui se passe?
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à madame
Agnès Firmin Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo:
Je vous rappelle
le Ségur de la santé.
les annonces pour valoriser
le travail de nuit à hauteur
de 1,1 milliard.
L'objectif numéro
1 est de rouvrir
des lits et d'assurer
des provisions médicales
et paramédicales
pour la formation.
Vous m'interrogez
sur un hôpital précisément.
Je suis en lien
avec les services
de l'Etat.
A la suite
de différentes plaintes
de familles de patients,
plusieurs inspections
de l'ARS se sont tenues.
Les rapports d'inspection
et les mesures correctives
ont été partagés.
Ils soulignent des problèmes
d'organisation interne.
Les événements graves
de ces derniers jours
ont suscité, par mesure
de précaution,
la suspension
d'activités de chirurgie
non programmées.
Tous les acteurs sont mobilisés.
Un plan d'action
est élaboré
et son déploiement sera
suivi par l'ARS.
Une attention
particulière est portée
aux équipes
pour restaurer un climat
de confiance.
La direction
de l'établissement
et de l'ARS travaille aussi
à des propositions
en ce sens.
Les services de l'Etat sont donc
pleinement mobilisés.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
Monsieur le député?
- Christophe Naegelen: Merci.
Au-delà des réponses
qui ont été données,
j'attire réellement
votre attention
sur l'état
dans lequel se trouve
le centre hospitalier
dont j'ai parlé.
J'invite le ministre
de la Santé
à se rendre sur place.
On a besoin
d'un message fort
de notre ministre.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
Je voudrais
indiquer
que lors de la prise de parole
de monsieur Jean-Paul Lecoq,
le le mot "assassin"
a été prononcé.
Une investigation
plus précise
va avoir lieu.
Monsieur François
Gernigon,
vous avez la parole.
- François Gernigon: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
du Logement.
Il y a deux ans,
le gouvernement a annoncé
la mise en place de MaPrimeAdapt'.
Ce dispositif vise
à soutenir nos concitoyens
de plus de 70 ans en offrant
un accompagnement
et une aide financière
aux ménages destinés
à adapter leur logement face
à la perte d'autonomie.
Ce dispositif,
alors que 10.000 seniors meurent
chaque année suite
à une mauvaise chute,
s'inscrit dans une démarche
de bien-être.
L'une
des caractéristiques phares
de cette prime réside
dans l'association d'une expertise
professionnelle
à la mise en oeuvre
des adaptations.
Il a été évoqué
l'intervention
d'un ergothérapeute
pour établir
un diagnostic précis
du logement, garantissant
que les travaux
soient en phase
avec les besoins réels
du bénéficiaire.
L'importance d'impliquer
des entreprises habilitées
a aussi été soulignée.
Cela assure la qualité
et la conformité
dans les réalisations.
Ce dispositif
s'inscrit parfaitement
dans la lignée
des engagements pris
par le gouvernement
pour renforcer
notre politique
en faveur du grand âge.
Bien que nous ayons
encore du chemin
à parcourir pour bâtir
notre modèle
de demain, notamment
en ce qui concerne
le maintien à domicile,
cette prime constitue
une pièce maîtresse
de cette vision,
dont la question du logement fait
partie intégrante.
Après consultation des services
de l'Agence nationale
de l'habitat,
il m'a été rapporté
un manque de directives
claires transmises
à ces organismes.
Nous sommes à deux mois
de l'entrée
en vigueur de cette mesure
et une telle situation soulève
de légitimes interrogations.
Monsieur le ministre,
j'aimerais savoir
où vous en êtes dans la mise
en place opérationnelle
de ce dispositif.
Quelles sont les instructions
données?
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole
est à Patrice Vergriete.
- Patrice Vergriete:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le député,
d'abord,
vous avez raison,
notre pays vit
une transition démographique
extrêmement forte.
En 2050, un tiers
des Français aura
plus de 60 ans.
Seulement 6% du parc
de logements
a été adapté.
On constate encore 10.000
chutes mortelles
chaque année.
Cela doit être amélioré.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle madame
la ministre a annoncé
la création
de MaPrimeAdapt'.
Ce fonds d'aide sera géré
par l'Agence nationale
de l'habitat que vous avez citée.
Il y aura un montant
de 250 millions
pour 2024.
Cela sera distribué
aux plus de 70 ans.
Les aides pourront
aller jusqu'à 68%
du montant des travaux
pour les ménages
les plus modestes.
Nous envisageons l'adaptation
de 700.000 logements
dans les 10 ans à venir.
Le dispositif
sera aussi ouvert
aux personnes
en situation de handicap.
Les instructions
ont été données,
mais j'aurai
l'occasion de refaire
le point avec les services
concernés.
Je voulais aussi dire qu'avec
ma collègue Aurore Bergé,
nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir
sur cette disposition.
Nous vous donnerons
l'ensemble des détails.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à Murielle Lepvraud.
- Murielle Lepvraud: Merci.
L'heure n'a jamais
été aussi grave
pour nos EHPAD.
En début d'année,
une enquête
de la Fédération
hospitalière de France
a alerté sur la situation.
A la fin
de l'exercice 2022,
85% des EHPAD publics
étaient déficitaires.
Les primes Grand
âge et Ségur
étaient plus qu'attendues,
mais comment expliquer
qu'elles ne soient pas entièrement
financées
par l'Etat?
Sans compter
que cela s'ajoute
à la hausse des prix
de l'énergie
et de l'alimentation.
Ce n'est plus tenable.
Les directrices et directeurs
des EHPAD font face
à un dilemme:
suspendre le paiement
des factures ou utiliser
le personnel
comme variable
d'ajustement, au risque
de priver les résidents
d'un accompagnement adapté.
On commence
à avoir des EHPAD fermés.
C'était le cas
récemment à Brest
pour deux établissements.
Qu'advient-il des familles,
des résidents,
des personnels?
Les citoyens s'organisent
pour combler l'inaction
de l'Etat.
C'est le cas
dans ma circonscription.
Des habitants
vendent des crêpes
sur le marché
pour aider l'EHPAD,
alors que c'est à vous d'agir.
Les scandales ne cessent
d'augmenter, cependant.
D'autres groupes sont accusés
de maltraitance.
Une proposition
de loi a été lancée
contre cette maltraitance.
Avec davantage de contrôle,
le scandale d'Orpea aurait pu
être évité.
Favoriser la course
au profit révèle
le cynisme
de votre politique de santé,
loin de tout esprit de solidarité.
Le PLFSS
que vous allez imposer
n'est pas à la hauteur.
Quant à la loi
du bien vieillir,
nous attendons les débats
qui s'imposent.
Face à l'urgence
de la situation,
que comptez-vous faire?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à Aurore Bergé.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci.
Madame la députée,
ce n'est pas juste
ce qu'on va faire
maintenant,
mais ce qu'on fait depuis 2017.
Ce que l'on fait
en matière d'autonomie,
c'est la création d'une
cinquième branche,
dont vous avez voté la création.
Il y a eu des revalorisations
de 900.000 personnels
en EHPAD.
Il y en a eu aussi
dans l'ensemble
des ECNS.
En tout, c'est 3,5 milliards
d'euros investis.
Il y a aussi eu un bouclier
énergétique mis
en place avec une compensation
de l'inflation
de 200 millions d'euros en 2023.
Cette compensation
va continuer
sur les enjeux
énergétiques en 2024.
L'engagement de l'Etat
est très clair
en matière de revalorisation
des personnels.
Tout ce que vous dites...
Vous auriez pu saisir
votre question
pour d'abord remercier
ceux qui s'engagent
au quotidien auprès
des personnes âgées
et celles qui sont en perte
d'autonomie.
En réalité,
c'est sur eux que repose l'effort.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
nous inscrivons
la trajectoire d'une garantie
de 50.000 personnels d'ici 2030
avec 6000 postes.
Quand vous êtes
moins démagogique,
vous savez que pour arriver
à la création
de ces postes, il faut créer
de l'attractivité,
des postes mieux
rémunérés, recréer
de la vocation.
Si vous voulez dire
que la situation
est désastreuse,
forcément,
vous n'arriverez pas à recréer
de l'attractivité.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à Stéphanie Rist.
- Stéphanie Rist: Merci.
Nous débutons cet
après-midi l'examen
du budget
de la Sécurité sociale
pour 2024.
Ce budget, c'est 643
milliards d'euros,
un tiers de notre richesse
nationale
pour protéger nos concitoyens.
Ce budget doit s'inscrire
dans une trajectoire
de maîtrise
de notre déficit public,
tout en poursuivant
la transformation
de notre système de santé.
C'est un budget engagé
dans la prévention
avec le financement
des campagnes
de vaccination
contre le papillomavirus,
la gratuité
des préservatifs
pour les moins de 26 ans.
Il est engagé
dans l'amélioration
de l'accès aux soins,
avec la possibilité
de donner des antibiotiques
pour certaines infections.
Ce budget prévoit en 2024
une augmentation
de 8 milliards d'euros
pour l'Assurance maladie.
On est loin de l'austérité
proclamée
par nos oppositions.
En commission,
de nombreux amendements
ont été adoptés.
Nous avons porté
avec la majorité
des amendements
qui renforcent la prévention
avec le dépistage
systématique
d'un virus pour les femmes
enceintes.
J'aimerais
avoir votre avis
sur vos intentions sur ces sujets.
Je vous remercie.
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à Agnès Firmin
Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo:
Madame la députée,
vous l'avez souligné,
nous allons bientôt débuter
l'examen du PLFSS
et de son budget.
C'est un budget engagé
et responsable.
Je vous remercie
d'avoir souligné
la réalité
des chiffres du budget
de la Sécurité sociale:
643 milliards d'euros
pour 2024.
Depuis 2017, c'est 54 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires
qui ont été consacrés
à la santé,
contre 10 milliards
sur le mandat précédent.
C'est inédit.
Cela traduit
l'engagement sans faille
du gouvernement
pour investir
dans notre système de santé.
Nous voulons assurer
la pérennité
de notre modèle
social pour protéger
les Français.
Le gouvernement
partage pleinement
les propositions que vous portez.
C'était l'esprit
de la coconstruction
que nous entendons porter,
en particulier
sur les deux pistes
que vous avez évoquées.
Vous pouvez compter
sur notre soutien.
Nous partageons l'ambition
d'un virage préventif.
Sur la dialyse
et la radiothérapie,
nous souhaitons
avancer
avec vous sur ce sujet.
C'est un travail
qu'il faudra mener
de façon concertée
avec tous les acteurs,
en privilégiant
la qualité des parcours
des patients.
Concernant les proches
aidants, Aurore Bergé
a proposé une stratégie récemment.
Nous avons encore beaucoup
à faire.
Le gouvernement
est pleinement ouvert
au débat parlementaire
sur ce texte essentiel
pour notre pays.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à Frédéric
Cabrolier.
- Frédéric Cabrolier:
Madame la présidente,
mes chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Ce samedi,
des incidents graves
se sont produits
dans le Tarn
lors de la manifestation
contre l'autoroute
Castres-Toulouse.
Plusieurs centaines
d'individus
ont dégradé
deux entreprises du BTP
en brûlant
des camions,
mais s'en sont aussi pris
aux sapeurs-pompiers
qui intervenaient,
à un vigile d'une entreprise
de BTP ainsi qu'aux
forces de l'ordre.
J'apporte mon soutien
aussi aux gendarmes
et policiers blessés,
ainsi qu'aux responsables
et salariés
des entreprises prises
pour cible.
Les forces de l'ordre
ont heureusement saisi
des armes par destination.
Barres de fer, pioches,
masques à gaz, couteaux,
ils ont évité
des faits
encore plus graves.
Seulement neuf personnes
ont été interpellées
sur les 2000 activistes
violents présents
de cette manifestation.
D'autre part,
des députés NUPES,
cinq avec leur écharpe
tricolore,
étaient présents,
comme souvent
dans ce type de manifestation
violente, cautionnant
ainsi ces actes par leur présence.
- Valérie Rabault:
Seul monsieur
le député a la parole.
- Frédéric Cabrolier:
Ils ont affirmé
que la manifestation
était pacifique.
Ils n'ont pas parlé
de violence,
mais de dégradation.
Une députée a même
justifié l'incendie
de camions
dans une cimenterie
par le fait que l'industrie
du ciment polluait beaucoup.
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Après le ministre
en charge des Transports,
je vais rendre hommage
aussi aux policiers
et gendarmes,
aux sapeurs-pompiers
ainsi qu'à monsieur
le préfet du Tarn,
qui a su répondre
aux manifestations
qui se sont déroulées
en dehors
de leur déclaration,
mais aussi
aux personnes
particulièrement violentes.
Cela avait été annoncé
par le collectif
Les Soulèvements de la Terre.
12 personnes ont été interpellées.
Quatre camions ont été brûlés.
Un bâtiment a été incendié.
20 drones
ont été utilisés
par ceux qui voulaient
coordonner
les actions
de lancers de pierres
et de cocktails
contre les policiers
et gendarmes.
Un certain nombre
de personnes violentes,
une centaine,
se sont installées
sans droit ni titre
dans une ferme,
voulant y installer une ZAD.
Les consignes
pour les forces de l'ordre
ont été claires.
Elles ont évacué ces personnes.
Les policiers et gendarmes
ont subi énormément
de violences
dans des conditions
de grandes difficultés
pour le maintien
de l'ordre.
12 personnes ont été
interpellées, certaines
avec des armes.
Elles ont été
présentées au service
du ministère de la Justice.
- Valérie Rabault:
Seul monsieur
le ministre à la parole,
s'il vous plaît.
Brouhaha
- Gérald Darmanin:
Le travail du ministère
de l'Intérieur
n'est pas de juger
de la qualité d'un projet,
mais d'appliquer
les décisions
de justice lorsqu'elles
ont été rendues.
C'est grâce à l'autorité
des magistrats
que cette manifestation
a été mise
en place.
On devrait respecter
le droit lorsqu'on
est élu, et aucune ZAD
ne sera constituée
tant que je serai
ministre de l'Intérieur.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Isabelle Valentin.
- Isabelle Valentin: Merci.
Le discours
était parfait,
mais entre le discours
et
la réalité des faits,
l'écart est abyssale.
Il s'agissait de soi-disant
mieux appréhender
les enjeux
du vieillissement,
de mieux appréhender
la dépendance
et le handicap.
Le rapport a été
rédigé
sans aucune concertation
avec les départements.
C'est un fabuleux
exercice technocratique,
déconnecté du besoin
des territoires,
des parcours de patients
et des attentes
des personnels de santé.
Je voudrais savoir
ce que nous allons faire
des enfants en situation
de handicap
sur liste d'attente,
des jeunes adultes maintenus
en établissement
enfants en attente
de place dans le secteur
adultes,
des enfants accueillis en foyer
de l'enfance faute
de plaintes en pédopsychiatrie.
Tant de questions
sans réponse,
qui témoignent du manque
urgent de moyens,
d'anticipation,
mais aussi d'un gouvernement
totalement hors sol.
On aurait pu penser que le PLFSS
2024 allait donner
une lueur d'espoir.
Il n'en est rien.
La cinquième branche
n'est pas assez financée.
Ce ne sont pas ces petites
mesures
qui vont sauver
notre système de santé.
70% des EHPAD sont déficitaires.
Il manque 2 milliards
d'euros en 2023
et 2 milliards en 2024.
Des pharmacies
rurales ferment
leurs portes.
Les infirmiers
et kinés tentent
comme ils peuvent
de maintenir les soins
à domicile.
La nomenclature
n'a pas été revue
depuis 2009.
L'argent n'est pas fléché
au bon endroit,
comme vous l'avez dit.
Il y a trop
d'administratifs
et pas assez de soignants.
Je n'ose
même pas vous demander
votre vision à long
et moyen terme
dans vos discours
qui ne sont que des paroles.
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à madame Aurore
Bergé.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci.
Une première réponse
sur la question
des adultes en situation
de handicap,
et donc celle
des enfants,
ainsi que sur la question
de l'autonomie.
On a aujourd'hui 10.000
adultes en situation
de handicap qui restent
dans des établissements dédiés
à nos enfants.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle on a annoncé
50.000 nouvelles solutions.
Nous allons en priorité créer
de nouvelles places
dans les établissements
médico-sociaux
et éducatifs.
Il n'y a pas un seul député
dans cet hémicycle
qui n'a pas,
dans sa permanence,
été contacté
par des parents
ou des familles
d'enfants en situation
de handicap
qui n'ont pas le bon niveau
de solution.
Notre première
responsabilité est d'abord
la création de places
pour les adultes
en situation
de handicap de manière
à faire en sorte
que chacun soit considéré
avec dignité
et soit à la bonne place.
Sur la question
de l'autonomie,
en 2024, 40 milliards
d'euros seront intégrés
au financement.
En 2027, nous atteindrons 45
milliards d'euros.
Un arbitrage très clair
a été rendu afin
que l'on puisse
adapter notre société
au vieillissement.
Il faut accepter
qu'en 2030, il y aura
plus de Français
qui auront
plus de 65 ans.
C'est un basculement démographique
majeur auquel l'ensemble
de la société doit
pouvoir s'adapter.
D'où une montée en charge
budgétaire puissante.
La proposition de loi a été
largement soutenue
par les parlementaires.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Richard Ramos.
- Richard Ramos: Merci.
Ma question faite
maison s'adresse
à la ministre Olivia Grégoire.
Je vous sais
gastronome, au sens
du partage de la table,
qui est ce lieu d'échange.
Nous avons l'amour d'une
bonne blanquette
ou d'un bourguignon
longuement mijoté.
Manger, c'est raconter
une histoire.
Manger, ce n'est pas mettre
des calories
entre la lèvre supérieure
et la lèvre inférieure,
c'est raconter
une géographie,
des tours de main
ancestraux et présents.
Manger,
c'est nos grands chefs,
mais aussi les 175.000
restaurants français
où on mange avec ses collègues,
sa famille.
C'est un repas
de communion, de mariage.
Ce sont des moments
qui rythment
nos vies, celles
de nos familles
et de nos proches.
Le mot "cuisiner"
est apparu au 13e siècle.
Il s'agit de faire
de la nourriture,
de transformer des produits bruts.
Quand nous recherchons
un restaurant,
nous recherchons
en fait un cuisinier
ou une cuisinière,
une signature personnelle
dans l'assiette,
quelle que soit la sophistication
du plat.
Nous avons tous mangé
une mauvaise salade César
avec une mauvaise
vinaigrette industrielle.
Nous devons combattre l'idée
qu'un restaurant doit
être modélisé par des goûts
industrialisés,
car modéliser les goûts,
c'est modéliser
les pensées.
Merci pour ce combat
courageux
que vous menez
pour faire en sorte
que nos restaurants
deviennent de vrais lieux
de cuisine, aujourd'hui et demain.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur
le député Ramos,
nous sommes nombreux
sur ces bancs
à connaître et saluer
l'engagement
qui est le vôtre
depuis des années
en faveur
du mieux manger
et du bien manger.
Nous avons en commun
la gastronomie,
mais aussi l'amitié.
Monsieur Paul Bocuse
le disait, il n'y
a pas de bonne
cuisine
si elle n'est pas faite
par amitié
pour celui ou celle
à qui elle est destinée.
Entre amis, on ne triche pas.
La gastronomie,
c'est l'art de transformer
des produits bruts
sur place pour créer
des émotions.
On ne peut pas,
dans notre pays,
à quelques mois
des JO,
alors que le monde
entier va venir
en France découvrir nos goûts,
nos produits bruts,
on ne peut pas ne pas mieux
informer
nos consommateurs
sur la réalité
de ce qu'ils mangent
au restaurant.
Parce qu'entre
amis,
on ne doit pas tricher.
Nous avons donc
écouté le terrain
pendant des mois.
Ceux qui cuisinent,
ceux qui sont nos restaurateurs
et qui transforment
nos produits bruts.
A force d'écouter,
nous avons entendu.
Je veux remercier
nos soutiens
pour cette mesure
simple et de bon sens:
obliger les restaurateurs
d'indiquer
sur le menu
les plats
qui ne sont pas préparés
sur place.
C'est une mesure
de bon sens
pour le producteur,
pour nos restaurateurs,
pour nos consommateurs.
Au-delà du label Fait maison,
un astérisque,
une étoile, une mention claire
est obligatoire afin
que le consommateur
sache si le produit
a été fabriqué maison ou pas.
Entre amis, on ne se juge pas.
Je n'ai pas
non plus de jugement
de valeur sur les produits
industriels.
On peut aussi
acheter un pâté
ou une pâte feuilletée
chez un artisan
et le servir...
- Valérie Rabault:
Merci, madame
la ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
David Taupiac.
- David Taupiac: Merci.
Alors que nous commençons
l'examen
du PLFSS pour 2024,
les engagements pris
dans le précédent
n'ont pas tous été respectés.
En engageant
votre responsabilité
avec un 49.3,
vous aviez néanmoins retenu
une demande
de rapport proposé
par notre groupe.
Il fallait identifier
les professionnels
du soin, du médico-social
et du social
qui n'auraient pas bénéficié
des mesures
de revalorisation
prises dans le cadre
du Ségur de la santé.
Très attendu
par ces personnels,
le rapport devait être remis
au Parlement fin juin.
Il n'en a rien été.
Je n'ai pas à vous rappeler
combien,
trois ans après ces rapports,
il existe
encore de nombreuses
inégalités
entre les personnels
sans que l'on puisse
avoir une vision claire
de la situation.
Beaucoup
de personnels
n'ont pas vu la couleur
de la prime promise l'année
dernière.
Nous parlons
de personnels
avec des salaires
proches du SMIC,
qui subissent de plein
fouet la crise
de l'inflation.
Considérant le verre
à moitié plein,
vous affirmez que ce sont près
de 700.000 salariés
qui ont été revalorisés.
Certes, nous nous en félicitons.
Mais combien sont encore exclus?
Nous avons tous
sur nos circonscriptions
suffisamment d'exemples
pour suggérer
que ce rapport amènerait
une clarification bienvenue.
Alors que le débat sera
interrompu prochainement
par un nouvel usage
du 49.3, je regrette
par avance
que nous ne pourrons
pas échanger
sur les amendements déposés
par le groupe LIOT.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Aurore Bergé.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
j'ai déjà appris
que vous n'aviez pas
encore reçu
le rapport qui devait
vous être remis.
J'ai donc interrogé
les services
pour qu'il vous soit
remis avant la fin
du mois, comme c'était
nécessaire
et que ce soit le cas
de manière
à ce que l'ensemble
des délais soient tenus
à l'avenir.
C'est ce que le gouvernement
doit
aux parlementaires.
Sur la question
de la revalorisation
et du Ségur,
on a 900.000 personnels
qui ont été revalorisés
dans les établissements
médico-sociaux.
Cela veut dire l'intégralité
des personnels
des EHPAD et tous
les personnels soignants,
socio-éducatifs
dans l'ensemble
des autres établissements.
On a donc un engagement
sur 900.000
de ces professionnels
qui ont été revalorisés,
pour un engagement de l'Etat
de 3,5 milliards d'euros.
Je suis vigilante
à ce que,
sur toutes les nouvelles
mesures,
on reconnaisse des mesures
qui ont pu exister.
Je vous annonce
aujourd'hui
que sur le privé
non lucratif,
cette mesure
sera étendue
pour qu'il y ait
la même symétrie
entre les établissements
sanitaires
et les établissements
médico-sociaux.
Dans le PLFSS 2024
que vous allez examiner
à partir d'aujourd'hui,
on marche
sur deux jambes,
sanitaire et médico-sociale.
Ces deux branches sont conjointes.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Julie Laernoes.
- Julie Laernoes: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à madame Sarah El Haïry.
Le constat est sans appel.
La biodiversité
est en chute libre.
Des milliers
de scientifiques ont établi
ce constat.
Cela provoque
de graves effets
sur nos conditions
de vie sur Terre.
Que proposez-vous
pour faire face
à cette sixième
extinction de masse?
Un loto!
Vous comptez lever 6
millions d'euros
alors qu'il en faut
600 millions
pour être à la hauteur du défi?
Cette sinistre
initiative ne sert
que la logique libérale
de la Française
des Jeux.
Elle renforce
les pratiques inductives
des plus fragiles.
Elle entretient
de manière peu éthique
la confusion
entre jeux d'argent
et intérêt général.
C'est irresponsable
et inconscient.
Derrière cette opération
de communication,
vous masquez
votre incompétence crasse.
Qu'avez-vous dit sur les projets
d'artificialisation
de milliers d'hectares
de zones humides
et boisées,
comme sur l'autoroute A69?
Vous êtes-vous indignée face
à la prolongation
de l'autorisation du glyphosate?
Non!
L'artificialisation
des sols
et les pesticides
sont les causes premières
de la perte de biodiversité.
La préservation
de la biodiversité
se joue-t-elle au hasard?
Allez-vous enfin
vous former aux enjeux
de la biodiversité pour pouvoir
prétendre défendre
la cause que vous êtes supposée
défendre?
Merci.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Sarah El Haïry.
- Sarah El Haïry:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs les députés.
Soyons sérieux deux minutes.
Le budget
de la biodiversité,
de la préservation de la nature,
n'a jamais été aussi important
que sous ce gouvernement.
Il a été
multiplié
par quatre entre votre départ
du pouvoir
et notre arrivée.
Le budget présenté
dans cette loi
de finance, c'est 1,2 milliard
d'euros d'augmentation.
C'est deux fois
les 600 millions
dont vous parlez.
La préservation
de la biodiversité,
c'est la stratégie
nationale
que nous travaillons,
avec les scientifiques,
avec les associations
et les élus locaux.
Nous voulons
restaurer la nature
et mobiliser tous les Français.
Je ne fais pas le tri
entre les Français.
Oui, j'aime l'idée
que l'on mobilise,
à l'image du loto
du patrimoine,
les Français
qui vont jouer,
pour qu'ils puissent
découvrir 20 projets
qui permettent
la préservation
de la biodiversité
et qui sont au plus proche
de chez nous.
La biodiversité
est aussi une affaire
de proximité.
Vous voulez essayer
de faire croire
que le budget est réduit à 6
millions d'euros,
c'est faux.
C'est 10 milliards
d'augmentation
du ministère
de l'Ecologie, rien
que dans ce PLFSS.
La biodiversité,
c'est la mobilisation
de tous.
Soyez du côté
de ceux qui réunissent
les Français.
Vous avez l'opportunité
de le faire aujourd'hui
avec un jeu populaire.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
Madame la députée?
- Julie Laernoes:
Je vous propose
un loto des ministres
pour participer réellement
à une formation
sur les enjeux
de la biodiversité.
Ceci permettra
peut-être de participer
à une manifestation
des Soulèvements
de la Terre, également.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la ministre.
- Sarah El Haïry:
Madame la députée,
ne soyez pas insultante.
Vous n'avez pas l'exclusivité
de l'écologie
ou de l'engagement pour la nature.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Sébastien Rome.
- Sébastien Rome: Merci.
Madame la Première
ministre, avec 13 49.3,
vous avez démontré
votre incapacité
à trouver une méthode
démocratique
qui fasse République.
Lors des deux dernières
législatures,
par deux fois, tous
les parlementaires
ont eu la force de voter
une loi à l'unanimité.
Ces parlementaires,
dans certains sièges
encore ici, ont mis
en oeuvre l'idée
de la garantie d'emploi
contre le chômage,
et les territoires zéro
chômeur longue durée.
Selon vos mots
de juin 2021,
c'est une réussite.
Oui, en proposant
des emplois en CDI
sur des secteurs
non solvables
pour le marché,
mais radicalement utiles
pour l'écologie et le social.
Ces entreprises,
créées par les chômeurs eux-mêmes,
transforment
des déserts économiques
en bassin d'emplois.
Ces personnes sont en moyenne
privées d'emploi
depuis cinq ans.
La vie ne les épargne pas.
Ces personnes ont vécu
vos lois plein emploi
et retraite
comme autant de claques
les désignant
comme des citoyens
de second rang.
Dans certaines zones,
sur 80 embauches,
une seule personne
avait une voiture.
Plus de 150 personnes
ont depuis décroché
un CDI.
Que dites-vous
aux milliers de personnes
en France qui attendent
un emploi
dans leur commune,
à celles
et ceux qui vous écoutent
au balcon
ou à l'extérieur de l'Assemblée?
Allez-vous respecter
votre parole
et celle du président
de la République,
qui parle d'une
clé dans la lutte
contre la pauvreté
en ne retirant
pas 1 euro
à cette expérimentation?
Ou allez-vous laisser
de nombreuses personnes
au bord du chemin?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
vous avez conclu
votre question
en demandant
si nous allions
retirer de l'argent
à cette expérimentation.
Nous faisons mieux.
Dans le budget
2023,
que vous n'avez pas voté,
mais qui s'applique,
les fonds consacrés
à l'expérimentation territoires
zéro chômeurs, ce sont 44
millions d'euros.
Dans le budget 2024, 10% de plus.
Toutes les structures
d'insertion aimeraient
une augmentation pareille.
La deuxième
chose,
c'est que nous avons eu
des contacts...
Huées
La politesse n'a
toujours pas gagné
les bancs de La France Insoumise.
Nous avons eu des contacts
avec l'association territoires
zéro chômeurs.
Mon cabinet a dit
vendredi à l'association
que si le pilotage
était amélioré,
nous pourrions trouver 10 millions
d'euros supplémentaires
en 2024.
Ils ont refusé.
Il y a eu une évaluation
sur la mise
en oeuvre,
sur les engagements pris
par l'association
au niveau national.
Nous allons continuer
à soutenir,
mais le budget
de l'Etat
n'est pas sans fin.
Il nous faut du pilotage,
de la régulation.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean Terlier.
- Jean Terlier: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer concernant
les violences
de la manifestation
de ce week-end
contre le chantier autoroutier
entre Castres et Toulouse
et la tentative avortée
d'installation d'une
ZAD dans le Tarn.
Je remercie Clément Beaune
d'avoir rappelé
que ce projet a été déclaré
d'intérêt national
à la suite d'un long
parcours démocratique
qui a conduit la communauté
d'agglomération,
le département,
la région afin
de désenclaver le territoire
et favoriser l'emploi
de 80.000 personnes.
80% des habitants
du département attendent
cette autoroute.
Ce ne sont pas les tergiversations
d'une minorité
de soi-disant
militants écologistes
très préoccupés des habitants
qui doivent primer.
Nous remercions
les 1600 gendarmes
et policiers
déployés
ainsi que les sapeurs-pompiers.
Nous déplorons
que malgré les engagements
des organisateurs
de la manifestation,
des violences et des exactions
ont été commises
par plus de 2500
pseudo-écologistes radicalisés.
Sans la mise en place
de votre cellule anti-ZAD,
les exactions
auraient été
encore plus nombreuses.
Je voudrais votre sentiment
sur la nécessité
d'avoir une réflexion
sur la responsabilité
des organisateurs
de manifestations,
notamment lorsqu'il
est établi
qu'ils ont eu
la volonté manifeste
de s'affranchir
du parcours déclaré
de la manifestation,
qu'ils se sont rendus complices,
à tout le moins de manière
passive,
des violences
et exactions,
et ceux en présence de députés
de cet hémicycle.
- Valérie Rabault:
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Tous soutiennent ce projet
d'infrastructure reconnu d'utilité
publique.
Il est parfois
plus facile lorsqu'on
est élu parisien
d'avoir un avis
sur comment on doit
se déplacer
dans le Tarn.
En ce qui concerne ce projet
d'infrastructure
de transport,
je laisserai le ministre
des Transports
évoquer son utilité
et sa confirmation.
Je me concentrerai
sur la question
de l'ordre public.
Les policiers,
gendarmes et préfets
ne font qu'appliquer
les règles
de la loi que vous votez,
mesdames
et messieurs les parlementaires.
Il faut aussi appliquer
les décisions
de justice.
Dans le cas d'incidents,
dans ce cas précis,
la préfecture
du Tarn a discuté
avec les organisateurs.
Une partie d'entre
eux n'ont pas respecté
ce qui avait été
évoqué, notamment
le cheminement
des manifestations
et cortèges.
Des contrôles ont montré
que de nombreuses armes
ont été saisies.
C'est rare d'arriver
en manifestation
avec des pavés,
des couteaux, des marteaux.
20 drones ont été
utilisés et brouillés
par nos services.
Ils étaient destinés à voir
comment travaillaient
les forces de l'ordre.
12 interpellés
seront présentés
devant le service
de monsieur le garde
des Sceaux.
Nous allons garder le site
et voir comment mettre
en responsabilité une partie
des organisateurs
pour ne pas avoir tenu
les engagements
qu'ils étaient censés tenir.
- Yannick Monnet:
Dans notre pays,
nous ne prenons pas soin
de celles
et ceux qui prennent soin de nous.
Les sapeurs-pompiers
sont exposés
à de nombreuses
substances toxiques
lors de leurs interventions.
En 2022, l'exposition
professionnelle
des pompiers a été classée
comme cancérogène.
Un rapport a conclu en 2023
à la nécessité d'obtenir
des données fiables
afin de mettre
sur pied une veille
sanitaire
sur la question.
Aucune démarche
n'a été engagée
en ce sens.
Les cancers
sont plus fréquents
chez les sapeurs-pompiers.
Une alerte de 2019
a appelé à engager
une surveillance
épidémiologique,
y compris pour les pompiers
à la retraite.
Aux Etats-Unis,
28 types de cancer
sont reconnus en maladie
professionnelle
chez les pompiers.
En France, un seul,
le carcinome
du pharynx.
Les composés
chimiques présents
dans les meubles,
les mousses de matelas,
sont des perturbateurs
endocriniens reconnus.
Leur dangerosité est avérée.
Nos sapeurs-pompiers
y sont exposés,
y compris par contact
avec la peau,
malgré les équipements actuels.
Nous avons perdu
beaucoup trop de temps.
Allez-vous instaurer
une investigation
et engager des études
épidémiologiques
et biologiques
indispensables pour élargir
la liste des cancers
reconnus
comme maladie
professionnelle
chez nos sapeurs-pompiers?
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
je suis prêt à élargir
cette liste.
En effet, vous avez raison,
les sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels et volontaires,
contrairement
à d'autres pays,
n'ont pas le même suivi
épidémiologique en France.
Il est évident
que leurs interventions,
dans des cadres
de plus en plus dangereux,
les poussent sans doute
à contracter
des maladies extrêmement
graves, notamment
des cancers.
Voilà 2 ans que j'ai lancé
des travaux.
La médecine de prévention
doit pouvoir faire
que les sapeurs-pompiers
puissent
avoir au moins tous les 2 ans
une consultation médicale.
Nous sommes en retard
sur les données,
vous avez raison.
Il y a plus de six mois,
j'ai lancé
avec mes collègues de la santé
une étude épidémiologique
pour savoir
ce qui se passe
pendant la vie professionnelle
des sapeurs-pompiers afin
d'en tirer
toutes les conclusions
de suivi et d'accompagnement
professionnel.
Ce sera un travail
à faire également
avec les syndicats
des sapeurs-pompiers
et la fédération
des sapeurs-pompiers,
ainsi qu'avec
la direction générale
des services civils
et le ministère
de l'Intérieur.
Il faudra accompagner les agents.
Je m'engage, lorsque
ces résultats seront connus,
à revenir vers vous.
- Valérie Rabault:
Merci
pour votre réponse.
La séance des questions
au gouvernement
est terminée.